vous installlez nous allons débuter il
est
9h3
voilà alors mes chers collègues donc
très heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin donc il manque un peu de monde
mais je pense que à la fois voilà on est
semaine de Coré des mers
donc voilà alors nous allons entendre ce
matin Monsieur Frédéric Pacou qui est
bien connu dans cette maison candidat
proposé pour par le gouvernement au
fonction de président du conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
français du sang en application de
l'article L 14511 du code de la santé
publique sa nomination doit être
précédée de son audition par les
commissions compétentes du Parlement
sans que celle-ci soit suivie d'un vote
je vous précise que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qui sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande je
vous précise également que vous
trouverez le CV de Monsieur Pacou dans
desmire j'en écrit simplement qu'il a
débuté sa carrière au sein de
l'administration du Sénat et qu'il était
jusqu'à cette année chef du pôle
parlementaire au cabinet de la Première
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle que l'établissement français du
sang est un établissement public de
l'État créé le 1er janvier 2000 en
remplacement de l'Agence française du
sang il est l'unique opérateur de la
transfusion sanguine en France qui
recouvre le don de sang de plasma et de
plaquettes il organise des activités de
collecte du sang de préparation de
qualification des produits sanguins
ainsi que leur distribution aux
établissements de santé en 2002 ce sont
environ 2000 2700000 dons de sang qui
ont été effectué par
1545000 donneurs le FS assure aussi
l'approvisionnement en placement du
laboratoire français du fractionnement
et des biotechnologies qui fabriquent
les médicaments dérivés du sang voilà la
mission de de la FS est donc cruciale
car elle touche à l'indépendance
sanitaire de la France dès lors qui lu
revient de garantir l'autosuffisance
nationale en produits sgain nous
connaissons néanmoins les difficultés
financières que rencontre le FS qui
justifie une réforme de son mode de
financement qui était notamment inscrite
dans le pfss pour 2024 donc nous en
avons
débattu pour commencer monsieur Pacou je
vous laisse le soin de vous présenter et
de nous expliquer ce qui vous conduit
aujourd'hui à vous porter candidat à
l'exercice des fonctions de président et
je vous ai dit notamment qu'il serait
intéressant pour nous d'avoir aussi une
vision sur le fonctionnement de
l'établissement et ses perspective voilà
donc je vous laisse tout de suite la
parole pardon merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur générale
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis particulièrement honoré et ému
d'être avec vous pour cette audition
parce que comme vous l'avez av rappelé
monsieur le Président j'ai travaillé
pendant plus de cette année à quelques
mètres d'ici puisque j'étais à la
commission des lois donc
géographiquement c'était vraiment pas
très loin et pour la première fois je
viens devant votre commission à cette
place donc ça n'est pas un moment anodin
pour moi et puis je suis également
honoré et ému parce que le le FS comme
vous le savez est un établissement
exceptionnel à plus d'un titre parce
qu'il occupe une place tout à fait
remarquable dans notre système de santé
il joue un rôle vit
et aussi en raison des enjeux de de
souveraineté sanitaire qu'il concentre
comme vous l'avez rappelé c'est un
établissement présent sur l'ensemble du
territoire qui incarne une forme de lien
social et qui porte une grande capacité
d'innovation je sais le Sénat
particulièrement attentif à tous ces
enjeux comme l'a encore récemment montré
l'été dernier le rapport de Madame la
rapporteur générale et Madame leerou sur
le le financement des des organismes
financés par les régimes obligatoires de
base et je suis donc très heureux
d'évoquer ce ce sujet avec vous
aujourd'hui je reviendrai brièvement si
vous me le permettez monsieur le
Président sur les les principes qui ont
forgé l'identité de de l'établissement
avant de résumer en effet mon parcours
et d'évoquer les les défis que le FS
devra relevé dans les prochaines années
à titre limininaire je tiens à préciser
que je vais évoquer ces sujets avec
beaucoup d'humilité étant donné que je
n'exorce pas encore les les fonctions
envisagées que je ne connais pas
l'établissement de l'Intérieur euh bien
sûr je partagerai néanmoins avec vous
l'ensemble des connaissances que j'ai à
ce jour d'abord un un bref retour sur
l'histoire parce que elle est
déterminante pour comprendre ce qu'est
le FS et pour envisager d'y d'y
travailler euh l'établissement s'inscrit
comme vous le savez dans l'architecture
qui a été dessiné après le la crise du
sang contaminé par les lois de 1993 et
1998 pour assurer le plus haut niveau de
sécurité sanitaire c'est une
organisation qui sépare la mission de
collecte confiée à l'fs la mission de
fractionnement confiée au LFB et la
mission de contrôle et de régulation
aujourd'hui confié à la NSM le FS et ses
établissements régionaux sont agréés par
la NSM qui définit les bonnes pratiques
transfusionnell et organise
l'émovigilance ce cadre de sécurité
sitaire est également assuré par le Haut
Conseil de la santé publique qui
surveille en particulier les risques
émergents par santé publique France qui
assure la surveillance épidémiologique
des donneurs et bien sûr par la
Direction générale de la santé cette
exigence de sécurité sanitaireirigue
l'ensemble de l'établissement qui veille
à la sécurité des receveurs mais aussi
des donneurs et la loi place le respect
des des règles relatives à la qualité et
la sécurité des produits sanguins sous
le contrôle d'une personne responsable
qui est un un médecin ou un pharmacien
et qui est actuellement le docteur
Pascal Morel qui assure les les
fonctions de président par intérim de
l'établissement et dont je veux saluer
ici l'action outre cette exigence
première de sécurité le le FS porte
comme vous le savez deux principes
essentiels depuis sa création ces
principes ce sont l'éthique et la
souveraineté sanitaire les principes
éthiques ils sont fixés dans la loi ils
sont le bénévolat du don l'anonymat du
don et l'absence de profit le le modèle
français de de don du sang se fond donc
sur un acte de générosité de citoyenneté
c'est inscrit dans dans notre
fonctionnement dans notre modèle depuis
les années 50 chacun peut donc donner en
France sous réserve de respecter les
conditions d'éligibilité au don quel que
soit sa catégorie socio-professionnelle
ou son origine et dès lors que pour
donner son sang il faut respecter un
certain nombre de conditions liées aux
antécédents médicaux au voyages dans des
zones
tropicales il apparaît
préférable en effet que les personnes
qui veulent donner leur sang puissent le
faire hors de toute pression c'est pour
ça que le caractère altruiste du geste
est particulièrement important puisque
c'est en fait le premier maillon de de
la sécurité sanitaire et le bénévola est
aussi à mes yeux un atout important
parce qu'il permet à lefs de s'appuyer
sur un nombre très important vous l'avez
rappelé de donneur sur une base très
importante ce qui dans des situations de
tension ou de crise est une garantie de
sécurité ou et d'efficacité 3è et
dernier principe c'est celui de la
souveraineté sanitaire puisque le FS a
pour mission d'assurer à notre pays
l'autosuffisance en produits sanguins
des produits qui restent indispensables
aujourd'hui encore à la médecine les
personnels de le FS font vivre la chaîne
transfusionnelle au quotidien ils
permettent ainsi de soigner 1 million de
malades par an l'établissement emploie
aujourd'hui 9700 personnes réparties au
sein de 13 établissements régionaux
cette dimension territoriale est
essentielle non seulement pour la
collecte qui est assurée quasiment sur
l'ensemble du territoire il n'y a pas de
collecte ni en Guyane ni à Mayotte pour
l'instant elle est aussi essentielle
pour délivrer les produits sanguins au
1500 établissements de santé et les
association de ces de bénévoles joue
bien sûr un rôle indispensable au côté
des élus dans ce maillage territorial
puisque 75 % des collectes sont encore
des des collectes mobiles et donc nous
avons à l'fs un besoin essentiel des des
bénévoles pour organiser les collectes
pour promouvoir le modèle éthique pour
mobiliser les donneurs et enfin le le le
service public du sang c'est aussi à
lefs d'autres missions alors la collecte
de plasma pour fractionnement à
destination du LFB je vais y revenir
mais souligner aussi que le FS c'est le
plus grand laboratoire d'analyse
biologique de France des analyses
biologiques sur les dons des analyses
d'immunohématologie pour les receveurs
afin de veiller à la compatibilité de de
la transfusion et des analyses également
dans le cadre des greffes puisque le le
FS a aussi une activité de greffe de
cellules ou de tissu et c'est enfin pour
toutes ces raisons aussi un
établissement porteur d'excellence et
d'innovation avec des activités de
recherche que j'évoquerai également
alors mon parcours en en quelques mots
vous en avez évoquer quelques traits
distinctifs je l'ai entièrement consacré
au au service de l'État à des questions
principalement juridiques d'organisation
et de transformation impliquant en
général beaucoup de dialogue et de
diplomatie alors j'ai une formation au
départ en histoire en philosophie et
l'Institut d'études politiques de Paris
j'ai ensuite effectué j'étais l'un des
dans les toutous derniers à devoir le
faire après avoir réussi le concours
d'administrateur j'ai rempli mes
obligations à l'égard du service
national au secrétariat général de la
Défense nationale comme conseiller
juridique avant effectivement de devenir
administrateur du Sénat pendant une
quinzaine d'années j'ai exercé des
fonctions en cabinet notamment comme
directeur de cabinet du ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement entre 2014
et 2016 à un moment où était discuté la
loi santé de janvier 2016 qui a apporté
plusieurs modifications au à
l'Établissement français du sang début
2016 j'ai rejoint le Conseil d'État où
pendant 6 ans j'ai été rapporteur à la
première chambre de la section du
contentieux qui est une chambre qui
traite du contentieux du de la santé de
l'aide sociale du travail et de
l'Urbanisme j'ai également été chargé au
Conseil d'État en tant que rapporteur
général adjoint de l'élaboration de deux
études annuelles du Conseil l'une sur la
politique publique du sport et l'autre
sur l'évaluation des politiques
publiques et j'ai enfin été rapporteur à
la section de l'Intérieur parallèlement
à ces activités j'ai effectué plusieurs
missions auprès de de dirigeants
d'établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche qui
voulaient se
regrouper notamment dans le contexte des
des initiatives d'excellence et du
programme d'investissement d'avenir et
donc j'ai j'ai travaillé avec ces
établissements à des moments où il
voulit voilà ils étaient en période de
transformation donc ça a été des des
missions particulièrement passionnantes
et j'ai également effectué une mission
auprès du Haut Conseil pour l'évaluation
de la recherche et de l'enseignement
d'illeurs le hcrs à un moment où
également cet établissement s'est
réformé début 2022 je suis devenu
secrétaire général de la région
académique Île-de-France où là j'ai
piloté neu directions réparties dans
trois académies donc un contexte
institutionnel un peu
complexe avec des directions traitant de
la formation de l'orientation des
systèmes d'information du numérique
éducatif de l'immobilier des achats
euh donc ceci avant d'être appelé comme
vous l'avez rappelé au cabinet de la
Premier ministre pour être chef du pôle
parlementaire et questions
institutionnelles et je suis revenu au
Conseil d'État en septembre dernier
alors j'ai conscience que ce parcours ne
fait pas de moins un spécialiste de la
transfusion sanguine mais j'ai la
conviction que que mon expérience et et
mes compétences pourront être utiles à
l'Établissement français du sang mon
parcours m'a en particulier permis
d'acquérir une bonne connaissance du
fonctionnement de l'État il m'a amené à
entrer dans des dossiers techniques et
complexes et à préparer des dans le
dialogue des décisions sur des des
sujets parfois très sensibles je suis
particulièrement attaché au caractère
vital des missions de lefs mais aussi à
à la solidarité qu'exprime le modèle
éthique que j'ai évoqué
et à l'expertise que porte
l'établissement et il n'est pas
indifférent non plus que le FS soit je
pense un un acteur important de la
démocratie sanitaire l'échange le
dialogue avec les associations de
donneurs les bénévoles les patients sont
au cœur de son fonctionnement et contte
tenu de la dimension territoriale de
l'établissement je suis convaincu de la
nécessité de travailler au plus près des
territoires avec les élus avec les
associations qui connaissent le terrain
c'est un établissement qui n'a cessé de
se transformé depuis 23 ans grâce à son
organisation à sa réactivité il a su
faire face à des périodes difficiles les
les attentats euh l'épidémie de covid-19
des épisodes climatiques également qui
qui sont aussi des des moments où les
conditions de collecte sont parfois très
perturbées et je veux donc saluer le le
travail accompli par François toujass
qui a présidé l'établissement pendant 11
ans et saluer aussi l'engagement très
fort des personnels et des bénévoles cet
établissement il arrive aujourd'hui à un
tournant de sa jeune histoire et je veux
donc évoquer les les principaux défis
que devra relever le FS dans les années
à venir à tracer quelques perspectives
ces défis j'en citerai cinq principaux
l'autosuffisance encore et toujours la
réforme du modèle
économique sujet que vous connaissez
bien l'attractivité la collecte de
plasma et les activités de recherche
alors le premier défi pour l'fs reste
celui de l'autosuffisance en produits
sanguins comme vous le savez c'est la la
mission quotidienne de l'fs qui doit
assurer des stocks suffisants en
produits sanguins dont la durée de
conservation est limitée
l'autosuffisance c'est assurer que les
patients peuvent recevoir les produits
sanguins dont ils ont besoin quand ils
en ont besoin ça n'est jamais acquis et
surtout au-delà de la quantité en fait
c'est une il y a une dimension
qualitative essentielle pour garantir
l'accès des patients à une transfusion
sanguine compatible avec leur propre
groupe avec leur propre phénotype donc
au-delà de la question particulière des
sang rares nous avons dans notre
population une très grande diversité de
groupes sanguins et la diversité des
donneurs de sang doit refléter celle de
la population c'est particulièrement
important pour soigner la drpanocytose
dont le traitement peut nécessiter des
transfusions régulières pour en rester à
des notions simplement quantitatives
l'objectif est d'avoir un stock
d'environ 90000 poches de concentré de
Glob rouge ce qui signifie 12 à 15 jours
de de consommation le passage au dessous
de 20000 poches étant un C d'alerte qui
a été franchi deux fois en
2022 la crise sanitaire a permis à
l'établissement d'accélérer certaines
avancées avec le développement du don
sur rendez-vous de la téléassistance
médicale en collecte qui permett à un
infirmier de superviser une collecte
sous réserve d'avoir la possibilité de
contacter très facilement un médecin à
distance en cas de difficulté mais
l'appareil de collecte aujourd'hui n'a
pas retrouvé ses repères d'avant la
crise sanitaire il y a cela plusieurs
raisons les tensions en matière de
ressources humaines sur lesquelles je
reviendrai des collectes qui ont dû de
ce fait être
annulé et puis des moments où les
donneurs en fonction de la situation de
l'ambiant général dans notre pays sont
moins présents moins accessibles aux
incitations là or nous sommes dans dans
un moment où non seulement la la
évidemment la la question qualitative
que j'évoqué reste prê an mais on aura
aussi en
2024 par exemple les les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques ce qui signifie que les
stocks devront être à un haut niveau à
un moment où souvent il est plus
difficile pour lefs de les maintenir
assez haut niveau parce que c'est l'été
et que les conditions de la collecte
sont un peu modifié on aura aussi sans
doute à ce moment-là dans la région
parisienne des conditions de circulation
ou de mobilisation des donneurs qui
seront un peu différentes et donc le FS
et l'ensemble des parties prenantes bien
sûr devront mettre en place une
organisation adaptée pour répondre au
défis permanents de l'autosuffisance
j'entends poursuivre ce qui a été engagé
par les équipes de l'fs pour développer
les partenariats avec les associations
avec les collectivités pour renouveler
l'expérience du don et l'inscrire
pleinement dans la vie citoyenne au sens
large pour aller vers les jeunes et les
fidéliser pour promouvoir le don de sans
rare en menant un travail de terrain et
pour adapter le système de collecte dans
chaque région en en articulant les
maisons du don les collectes mobiles
afin de répondre Infiné qualitativement
aux besoins des patients le deuxème défi
c'est la réforme du modèle économique de
lefs modèle qui comme le rappellent les
rapporteurs de de votre commission sur
le projet de loi de de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 qui est
regardé comme insoutenable depuis le
rapport de la Cour des comptes de 2019
et on pourrait même remonter encore un
peu plus loin sur le diagnostic c'est un
modèle qui qui reposait sur la session
de produits sanguins aux établissements
de santé session qui a longtemps permis
de financer l'ensemble des activités et
qui représente toujours la la part la
plus importante de du chiffre d'affaires
de l'établissement néanmoins l'effet de
ciseau qu'évoquait le le rapport de de
juillet dernier c'est c'est confirmé ces
quatre dernières années une baisse de
recette une hausse des dépenses alors
pour pour ce qui est des de ces
difficultés financières les causes que
vous avez fort bien
analysé sont principalement exogènes il
y a le la modification du régime de TVA
en 2019 qui a généré pour le FS une
perte de près de 70 millions d'euros
compensé par une dotation de l'assurance
maladie qui devait être dégressive à
comptter de de
2019 il y a le donc le la baisse la
tendance à la baisse sur le long terme
de la session de de concentrer de
globule rouge alors qui tient qui s'est
accentué pendant la crise sanitaire du
fait de la réduction de l'activité
hospitalière mais qui est en fait une
baisse qui s'inscrit dans la longue
durée qu'on peut observer depuis 10
ans et qui se confirme et qui lié
fortement aux évolutions de la médecine
une médecine qui est moins consommatrice
de poche ce qui est une bonne chose
puisque en fait c'est ça veut dire qu'on
essaie de mieux utiliser les poches et
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle la gestion
du capital sanguin ou en anglais le
patient blood management auquel
contribue le le FS lui-même avec son
activité de conseil
transfusionnel c'est bien pour les
patients c'est puisque c'est plus de
sécurité ça veut dire prévenir pour les
personnes qui vont en à l'hôpital qui
vont être soignés prévenir le le
l'anémie prévenir les hémorragies
veiller à n'utiliser vraiment que la
transfusion dont la personne a besoin
euh et puis c'est c'est aussi lié à au
développement depuis le la fin de la
crise sanitaire de la médecine
ambulatoire qui est également moins
consommatrice de transfusion et donc le
FS doit faire avec ce ce tarissement de
de de la session de de concentré de de
globulle rouge mais qui est au fond une
bonne chose pour notre notre système de
santé simplement c'est un paramètre qui
modifie fondamentalement le
fonctionnement de
l'fs et enfin je ne serais pas complet
si je n'évoquait pas aussi le le déficit
que génère le la session de plasma pour
fractionnement au laboratoire français
du fractionnement etbiotechnologie
puisque ce plasma il est cédé à un prix
inférieur au coup de revient en
parallèle donc effet ciseau parce que on
a une augmentation des coûts liés à la
masse salariale à l'inflation bien sûr
et un établissement qui a exécuté des
budgets en déficit de 11 millions en
2019 et de 40 millions d'euros en
2022 une réduction des investissements
euh un coûpt d'arrêt au plan
d'efficience qui avait été lancé en 2019
coup d'arrêt lié à la crise sanitaire et
après plusieurs années où le FS a été
contraint de solliciter des des
subventions ponctuelles euh sans qu'il
ni donnait pas donc de de visibilité il
a été décidé dans le cadre du PLFSS 2024
d'apporter une réponse plus structurelle
en deux temps avec d'une part une
redéfinition des tarifs réglementés qui
doivront prendre davantage en compte le
coût de reviens réel des produits
sanguins c'est-à-dire leur coût de
production avec un objectif d'efficience
également et d'autre part une dotation
péren de l'Assurance Maladie dotation
qui serait de de 100 millions d'euros et
qui constitue une évolution majeure du
modèle économique qui devient mixte
cette dotation elle doit financer
l'émission de servicees public ou des
activités qui ne peuvent être valorisé
par la tarification elle doit financer
en particulier l'accès aux produits
sanguins sur l'ensemble du territoire
métropolitain et ultramarin dans délais
dans des délais compatibles avec les
besoins hospitaliers
elle devrait financer les
investissements dédiés au renouvellement
des actifs et à la conduite des
chantiers de modernisation ce qui me
semble déterminant c'est que cette
dotation marque une volonté claire
d'assurer la pérenité de l'établissement
elle représente un premier jalon vers
une reprise de la transformation de
l'établissement pour lui permettre de
rester à la pointe de la sécurité
sanitaire et de répondre à l'évolution
des besoins du système de santé elle
permettra au Parlement d'évoquer chaque
année le montant et l'utilisation de
cette dotation ce qui va assurer une
plus grande transparence et un meilleur
suivi de la situation de l'établissement
je sais que c'est un point auquel le
rapport de juillet dernier de votre
commission était particulièrement
attentif cette dotation à mon sens elle
devra être assortie d'objectifs et
d'outils évaluation en lien avec une
programmation des chantiers de
modernisation à conduire et je souhaite
que le nouveau contrat d'objectif et de
performance que devra conclure
l'établissement courant
2024-2025 définissent une stratégie
partagée avec l'État qui porte aussi
bien sur les ressources de
l'établissement que sur la poursuite de
sa transformation avec une trajectoire
d'efficience et pour ce pour appuyer ce
pilotage il me paraît souhaitable de
planifier les investissements d'affiner
la projection annuelle des sessions de
produits sanginabil parce que je pense
qu'on a besoin d'éléments plus précis
pour donner une plus grande
prévisibilité et permettre l'ajustement
enfin la poursuite de la la réforme de
ce modèle il faut aussi me semble-t-il
impliquer pleinement les établissements
régionaux qui connaissent le terrain et
travailler avec les ARS avec les
établissements de santé et avec les
associations cette révision du modèle
économique et de la stratégie ne pourra
se faire que dans le dialogue avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et donc la
relance du dialogue social sera une
condition essentielle ce qui m'amène au
3oème défi celui de l'attractivité qui
est un point que le FS a en partage avec
les établissements de santé qui
connaissent la même problématique le FS
ce sont 97 % de salariés de droit privés
2 tiers sont des femmes il s'agit de
3500 techniciens de laboratoire de 1500
infirmiers et infirmière diplômé d'état
de 800 biologistes médecins et
pharmaciens de 400 chauffeurs d'agents
de col
d'informaticien le taux de rotation
moyen des personnels
atteint allaigrement les les 10 %
actuellement 320 postes sont vacants
alors il y a le renouvellement normal
donc c'est c'est un chiffre global hein
qu'il faut donc pas prendre comme étant
purement et simplement le témoignage de
d'une de départ mais voilà au jour où
nous parlons il 320 postes vacants dont
près de 44 postes de biologistes ce qui
est déterminant le taux d'absentéisme
est élevé ce qui pèse sur l'organisation
des collectes il y a un petit passif
c'està-dire qu'il y a eu un peu de temps
qui a été mis pour l'application à l'fs
d'une partie des accords du segure de la
santé ce qui a pu laisser des traces en
matière de de dialogue social même si
une importante action de revalorisation
a été conduite en 2021 et 2022 des
élections professionnel viennent d'avoir
lieu la reprise du dialogue d'un
dialogue constructif sera au centre de
mes préoccupation parce que la qualité
du dialogue social déterminera largement
la capacité de l'établissement amener à
bien les transformations qui assureront
son avenir plusieurs évolutions ont déjà
été engagées pour faire face aux
difficultés de recrutement des décrets
qui comme vous le savez ont réformé les
conditions de qualification de certains
professionnels pour tenir compte de
l'expérience pour permettre aux
infirmiers par exemple de réaliser
l'entretien prédon après 3 mois
d'ancienneté au lieu de 2 ans
auparavant je souhaite que nous
puissions reprendre tous ces chantiers
concernant le dialogue social et les
ressources humaines procéder enfin à la
révision de la convention collective et
au et du système de classification afin
de définir des des parcours
professionnels plus attractif plus
dynamique pour euh que les les les gens
aient envie de rester à l'Établissement
français du sang mieux prendre en compte
les contraintes opérationnelles le
travail de nuit et les weekends
travailler sur la marque employeur
c'est-à-dire faire connaître
établissement et ses métiers et définir
une politique active de formation mon
ambition au fond c'est que la filière
française du sang et du plasma reste une
filière d'excellence et répondre à la
problématique de l'attractivité c'est se
donner les moyens aussi bien de
moderniser l'outil de collecte que
d'assurer l'autosuffisance de retrouver
une meilleure productivité et une plus
grande
efficience le 4è défi c'est celui de la
collecte de plasma pour fractionnement à
destination du LFB LFB qui produit donc
les médicaments dérivés du plasma qui
permet de soigner notamment les
personnes en réanimation qui souffrent
d'un déficit immunitaire ou les
personnes
hémophiles dans ce domaine les besoins
en immunoglobuline connaissent dans le
monde une croissance de 6 à 8 % par
an le laboratoire français couvre 35 %
des besoins de notre pays en
immunoglobuline ce sont 65 % des
médicaments dérivés du plasma qui sont
donc issus de de prélèvements effectué
sur des donneurs rémunérés
essentiellement aux États-Unis et le
donc le le développement de la collecte
de plasma en France est un enjeu à la
fois d'indépendance sanitaire de pour
répondre aux besoins des patients mais
aussi de cohérence avec notre modèle
éthique l'usine du laboratoire français
du fractionnement et des biotechnologies
à aras ouvrira en 2025 elle devrait être
pleinement opérationnelle en 2027 donc
les besoins du LFB vont augmenter après
les difficultés rencontrées en 2022 pour
assurer l'autosuffisance en produit
sanguin le FS devrait parvenir cette
année à produire 815000 l de plasma pour
fractionnement l'autosuffisance totale
en en plasma dans notre pays ne paraît
pas atteignable la plupart des pays
européens bien sûr ne l'atteignent pas
mais il paraît raisonnable d'avancer
vers une couverture de 50 % de nos
besoins ce qui permettrait au moins de
répondre avec la collecte étique aux
patients qui n'ont pas d'alternative
thérapeutique une première étape
consisterait à atteindre 1,4 million de
plasma collectés par le FS d'ici
2027 c'est compliqué parce que c'est une
collecte qui demeure moins connue les
personnes connaissent bien le le les
Français connaissent bien le don du sang
mais moins la collecte de plasma le don
de plasma c'est une collecte qui
mobilise les donneurs de façon plus
exigeante parce que ça prend plus de
temps c'est plutôt 1h3 1h50 que 50
minutes euh c'est une collecte qui n'a
lieu que dans les maisons du don il y en
a 90 aujourd'hui à l'fs donc qui peut
générer des déplacements là où les
collectes mobiles de sans total sont
plus en proximité mais c'est aussi une
collecte qui présente des avantages
parce que elle est moins fatigante elle
comporte moins de contreindication par
rapport à l'anémie moins de contrainte
aussi pour les sportifs on peut donner
son plasma tous les 15 jours entre 18 et
66 ans c'est-à-dire 24 fois dans l'année
donc c'est plus
c'est plus facile enfin dans ce sens là
sur le plan strictement
médical c'est plus facile et plus
fréquemment que le nom de s total la
France dispose d'un potentiel de
collecte important plusieurs pistes
existent pour avancer vers une
couverture de 5 % 50 % pardon des
besoins un décret a été publié le 5
novembre dernier qui va permettre par
exemple de mettre en uvre la
téléassistance médicale en collecte pour
la Plasma ferz donc ça va multiplier les
les capacités puisque les infirmiers
vont pouvoir superviser ces
collectes autre point la baisse de de
cession de des besoins de de concentré
globues rouge fait aussi que on peut
envisager une conversion si je puis dire
de l'appareil de collecte du sang total
vers la collecte de plasma c'est ça
n'est pas évident à mener mais il y a
donc un potentiel là aussi en complétant
le parc de machine en ouvrant de
nouveaux sites les différents acteurs FS
LFB ministère devront à mon sens se
mettre autour de la table pour fixer un
objectif et arrêter un plan de
développement mais il me semble qu'en
toute hypothèse le FS devra s'engager
pleinement pour développer cette filière
plasma 5è et dernier défi celui de la
recherche et du développement de la
filière française de bioproduction la
recherche s'est développée au sein de
l'fs parce que l'établissement détient
une expertise de la cellule sanguine
c'est une recherche qu'il a développé
d'abord au service de la transfusion
pour améliorer la PR en charge
thérapeutique et la sécurité sanitaire
et donc c'est une recherche qui s'est
d'abord fondée sur les sur les cellules
du sang et les tissus ce sont à le FS 18
équipe de recherche conjointe avec
l'incerme avec le CNRS avec les
universités présente dans neuf
établissements régionaux à partir de ces
activités de de thérapie cellulaire le
FS a développé d'une part de la
recherche des en en médecine
régénérative que ça soit sur la peau la
rétine ou le le cœur et aussi des
recherches en immunothérapie notamment
avec les cartis cells qui sont des des
lymphocytes biologiquement modifiés pour
traiter des lymphomes ou des leucémies
le FS propose son expertise en matière
de médicaments de thérapie innovante à
des structures industriell dans le cadre
de contrat de sous-traitance il dispose
pour cela de quatre plateformes qui
réalisent de la bioproduction pour le
compte de tiers il maîtrise une chaîne
de valeur qui va de la recherche
fondamentale aux patients avec des
essais cliniques aujourd'hui 95 % des
médicaments de thérapie innovante sont
fabriqués à l'étranger c'est une filière
qui revit donc une importance
stratégique pour notre souveraineté
sanitaire l'activité de FS vise à
proposer des biomédicaments à un prix
qui soit compatible avec notre modèle de
santé parce que ce sont des médicaments
dont le prix est assez
vertigineux je souhaite agir pour le
maintien de cet effort de recherche au
sein de l'établissement en lien avec les
organismes de recherche avec les
entreprises du secteur c'est pour moi
une AC une activité qui s'inscrit dans
l'histoire de l'fs qui assure sa
capacité à innover et qui montre
l'engagement de des personnels pour les
patients et elle me paraît indispensable
pour continuer à attirer les talents et
les compétences vous l'avez compris je
souhaite travailler pour la pérenité et
la modernisation de la filière française
du sang et du plasma avec un attachement
intangible à la sécurité sanitaire et au
modèle éthique j'accomplirai ma mission
en associant étroitement toutes les
parties prenantes les organisations
syndicales les associations de donneurs
et de patients le Parlement bien sûr les
sociétés savantes et en prenant
pleinement en compte la dimension
territoriale de l'fs faire vivre la
démocratie sanitaire me paraît
essentielle pour construire l'avenir et
maintenir la confiance je seraai
particulièrement attentif à la pleine
association des établissements de
transfusion régionaux la démarche de
transformation qui doit être conduite au
plus près du terrain j'y mettrai toutes
mes compétences et mon énergie
je vous
remercie très bien monsieur Pacou pour
cette
présentation je vais tout de suite
donner la la parole à à certain nombre
de nos collègues et je vais commencer
par
corinebert merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur pour votre présentation
et pour
ces cette cette feuille de route
j'allais dire que vous nous avez décliné
avec des des défis
importants si vous êtes nommé à à la
tête de de la FS vous ne vous ennuierez
pas je pense parce que les défis sont
effectivement colossaux alors une
question assez assez simple j'ai j'ai
trois petites question à vous poser la
première et vous l'avez évoqué sur sur
le modèle français du don avec son
l'éthique euh avec son caractère sur la
non rémunération du don donc le
bénévolat la le non profit et l'anonymat
et vous l'avez évoqué également sur les
réserves de sang qui à un moment donné
étaient passé en dessous des seuilles
d'alertes en 2022
euh un un un modèle qui est différent
dans des pays voisins où la rémunération
du don est est est proposé donc comment
selon vous favoriser la mobilisation des
donneurs et le modèle français doit-il
être questionné
euh on voit bien que l'après l'après
covid et pour aussi des des problèmes
d'organisation en interne c'estàd vous
avez évoqué l'annulation euh un peu à la
dernière minute de collecte faute de
faute de personnel et vous avez évoqué
le nombre de postes vacant qui est assez
important donc voilà est-ce qu'à un
moment donné vous vous êtes posé cette
question euh sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
euh recherche et je partage évidemment
tout toute l'importance qu'occupe le FS
dans dans la la recherche et euh et
notamment dans la production de de
biomédicaments vous avez évoqué
l'importation de de de plasma américain
euh est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
détailler peut-être un un un peu plus
comment vous allez euh le SF va se va se
positionner hein sur ces thérapie
innovante et et contribuer à la
consolidation de la filière française de
bioproduction importante pour pour les
patient et puis enfin une question qui
n'a rien à voir avec avec cela vous avez
évoqué le changement de régime de TVA
qui a pénalisé l'Établissement français
du sang est-ce que vous imaginez qu'on
puisse revenir en
arrière par rapport à à la TVA qui qui
est appliqué sur les produits voilà je
vous remercie merci maintenant je don la
parole à notre rapporteur général lesbè
douanau merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur pour votre état des lieux
présentés et aussi l'ambition que vous
portez pour cet établissement qui est
cher au cœur de tous les Françaises de
toutes les Françaises et les Français et
je peux vous dire que ici au Sénat on a
défendu le FS à tous les moments que ce
soit au PLFSS ou à à à des moments clés
aussi de la vie de votre établissement
euh donc donc j'ai pas beaucoup de
questions parce qu'en fait vous avez
répondu en partie à à ce que j'avais
préparé et moi je voudrais dire
simplement que vous arrivez à point
nommer parce que en réalité cet
établissement était en difficulté on va
dire en en en faillite financière que le
modèle n'était plus du tout adapté que
grâce à ce PLFSS 2024 voilà les choses
vont un peu changer mais est-ce qu'elles
vont changer je dirais suffisamment en
terme budgétaire parce que vous aviez
effectivement avant un modèle qui était
basé sur la vente des produits sanguins
Labil et rien sur effectivement ce qui
vous a donné aujourd'hui en terme de
forfait c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
correspond en terme de santé publique à
l'ouverture 7 jours sur 7 24 he sur 24
et puis vos fonctions aussi sur je
dirais vous l'avez très bien dit en
terme de démocratie sanitaire donc c'est
en terme de santé publique euh une
comment une juste reconnaissance de ce
que vous faites déjà donc ce forfait qui
en tout cas avait été quelque peu déjà
amorcé puisque cette année c'était 55
millions d'euros tout de même et que là
avec le plfs ce sera 100 millions
d'euros mais est-ce qu'il est envisagé
de faire un peu plus parce qu'en fait là
vous allez arriver vous allez pouvoir
voir réellement comment les choses se
passent et moi je pense que il y a deux
points sur lesquels j'aimerais insister
c'est la gestion du personnel parce
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit il y a
un un un un un gros problème parce que
on on l'a vu moi j'avais moi-même posé
une question gouvernement sur la
nonapplication du segéure ce qui a
complètement défavorisé
euh votre institution puisque vous ne
vous n'étiez pas aussi attractif que
d'autres établissements et donc là
j'aimerais savoir en fait il y a une
application donc retardée mais pas
forcément compensé donc j'aimerais avoir
quelques éléments là-dessus et puis com
on rendre plus attractif justement les
métiers de l'fs et puis en faire un
établissement qui soit rayonnant quoi
pour voilà attirer les les les talents
et puis le deuxième point c'est la
recherche parce qu'effectivement le la
la perspective de demain c'est proposé
sur sur sur notre comment pays mais
au-delà de notre pays une performance
une
qualité voir des des des des comment
dirais-je des produits qui soient très
innovants en tout cas en terme de de de
comment de qualité mais aussi peut-être
des des produits qui qui qui peuvent
attirer aussi des chercheurs d'ailleurs
pour justement chercher encore plus
parce qu' on sait jamais ce qu'on
cherche mais parfois on
trouve et donc en tout cas voilà moi les
deux questions c'est est-ce que ça va
être suffisant pour travailler sur
l'attractivité des métiers dans votre
établissement et sur le plan de la
recherche attirer les talents et aller
plus loin encore même dans ce qu'on peut
imaginer
aujourd'hui très bien merci beaucoup la
parole à Florence
lassarade merci leés monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur pour
votre enthousiasme à rejoindre ce poste
euh vous avez parlé de la je vais aller
dans le détail de la drpanocytose je
voudrais savoir quel quel coût ça a
quelle proportion dans la dans le nombre
de transfusions euh est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une idée et alors sur la
drpanocytose finalement est-ce que vous
vous travaillez
de est-ce que vous travaillerez avec les
spécialistes du sujet la Haute Autorité
de Santé a recommandé la généralisation
de la du dépistage systématique alors
qu'avant c'était uniquement sur un
antécédent ou sur les origines des des
parents
euh ensuite il y a un espoir
considérable avec la thérapie génique
donc probablement que les drpanocyires
n'auront quasiment plus besoin de
transfusion mais cette thérapie génique
elle est financée par la générosité euh
populaire en particulier par le Téléton
euh voilà j'aimerais avoir votre votre
point de vue sur le sur l'avenir et ce
ce ce coût de la prise en charge par
l'Établissement Français du sentre des
Dr panocitaire qui normalement devrait
baisser si du moins on va dans le bon
sens et en dépistage et en
thérapie merci
euh pour terminer cette première
question je donne la parole à Émilienne
pouirol euh oui merci monsieur le
président merci Monsieur pour votre
présentation en fait j'ai peu de choses
à redire puisque Corine et éisabe ont
dit l'essentiel de ce que je voulais
dire d'abord vous remercier pour
pour avoir envie de et de votre
enthousiasme sur sur ce poste sur
l'établissement français du sang qui est
effectivement unétablissement auquel
nous sommes très très attachés en
particulier sur la finre enfin sur le
bénévolat et sur ce sur l'éthique de de
ce de notre fonctionnement euh j'avais
moi aussi la question sur la TVA mais
Corine l'a posé je voulais vous avez
beaucoup insisté sur votre volonté de
dialogue et et c'est vrai que j'étais
allé je crois il y à peu près un an à
quelque chose près voir donc
l'établissement doncocitani qui qui est
à toulousein j'avais visité les locaux
et c'était extrêmement intéressant mais
c'est vrai qu'on avait attiré mon
attention sur ce problème d'attractivité
alors on a déjà parlé de du du du du
séure mais c'est vrai
que la direction me parlait de
différence de de 400 € par mois entre
l'établissement français du sang et
l'hôpital qui est il y a juste la rue à
traverser ou quasiment à Toulouse donc
c'est vrai que ils ont perdu beaucoup de
postes des gens qui ont effectivement
traversé la rue pour aller pour le même
travail ou même enfin à peu près le même
travail même s'ils sont passionnés par
ce qu'ils font 400 € par mois ça
commence à compter donc est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir rattraper ce retard euh et avoir
des des salaires corrects qui
reconnaissent vraiment le travail
extrêmement important et puis insistez
moi aussi sur la sur la l'importance de
la recherche et euh quand on voit le
prix effectivement aujourd'hui des
médicaments innovants je me dis que ce
serait extrêmement important qu'on
puisse avoir NRE recherche qu'elle soit
pas dépendant à ce point euh vous avez
parlé de 95 % médicaments qui viennent
de l'étranger euh si on pouvait
améliorer vraiment ce 95 % et peut-être
le transformer en 90 ou en 85 je ne sais
mais je pense que ce serait extrêmement
important sur le plan budgétaire aussi
merci merci Monsieur Pacou je vous
laisse répondre cette première S on a
encore quatre intervenants après
d'ailleurs merci monsieur le
Président alors
euh sur le le modèle français du don
éthique et et comment on peut si j'ai
bien compris votre
question
relever je dirais le double défi de la
collecte de voilà de sang total avec
problématique permanente
d'autosuffisance dans un contexte qui
est qui ressort un peu perturbé aussi
bien chez les donneurs parce que
vieillissement de la population parce
que les jeunes viennent une fois mais
pas forcément voilà il y a beaucoup de
jeunes par exemple qui qui donneent
un/ers des donneurs ont moins de 35 ans
mais ceux qui donnent un peu plus de de
fois par an ce sont plutôt les plus de
60 ans c'est sont plutôt ceux qui ont
entre 70 60 et 70 ils sont enfin le la
générosité pour la parce que c'est enfin
en terme statistique c'est qualifié
comme ça elle est plus forte voilà il y
a une question aussi de de faire revenir
les gens et que ça soit un peu plus de
un de dons par
an donc il y a le défi pour le S total
et puis le le défi pour la collecte de
plasma pour le LFB dans le
contexte comme vous l'avez évoqué qui
est un contexte européen où on a
différents
modèles plusieurs pays qui sont sur un
modèle éthique où il n'y a pas
de de d'incitation financière au
don qure pays en Europe qui procèdent à
une compensation forfaitaire qui peut
avoir un niveau plus ou moins incitatif
parce qu'elle est définie en général en
fonction
du taux horaire moyen de de salaire donc
ce sont
l'Autriche l'Allemagne la République
tchèque et si je ne me trompe pas la
Hongrie
euh
clairement ça n'est pas le modèle pour
répondre à ce premier point ça n'est pas
du
tout ce que ce que nous souhaitons en
revanche enin ce que ce que je je prône
en revanche pour remplir le répondre à
ce défi y a plusieurs plusieurs
axes il y a tout ce qu' engagé le FS
avec un programme qui s'appelle
innovadon
pour davantage utilis les outils
numériques c'est-à-dire possibilité de
prendre rendez-vous
pour donner son sang ou son
plasma possibilité de répondre sur une
application à un préquiz qui vous permet
très vite de savoir si aujourd'hui vous
pouvez donner ou pas alors vous
découvrez que vous avez fait un voyage
sous les tropiques en fait c'est pas
possible va falloir attendre 4 mois
enfin c'est plus facile c'est plus
attractif une politique de communication
qui doit aussi se faire sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui fonctionne plutôt assez
bien en ce moment il y en a une sur le
sur le plasma et donc là pour le les
publics jeunes c'est sans doute aussi un
un média qui peut fonctionner il y a
toute la problématique RH où là bon il y
a la question générale de l'attractivité
je je pourrais y revenir mais il y a
tout ce que le FS a engagé avec l'appui
du du ministère de la Santé pour faire
évoluer tout ce qu'on tout ce qui tourne
autour de la qualification de la
délégation de tâche et tout en euh
maintenant le plus haut degré de de
sécurité sanitaire utiliser faire appel
aux compétences qu' qu'on détiens
c'est-à-dire donc l'entretien prédon
infirmier euh la téléassistance médicale
en collecte le fait de de permettre à
des techniciens sous supervision de
certains biologistes de faire des de
remplir euh certaines missions donc il
il y a des réponses
euh
structurelles après il y a la la grosse
question qui qui j'imagine que le Sénat
aussi il est très attentif de de
l'équilibre entre les collectes mobiles
les maisons du don je sais que ça c'est
un élément qui
peut rendre plus compliqué
l'intervention des des amicales et des
bénévoles parce que le plasma feris par
exemple c'est dans les maisons du don il
y en a 90 le rôle des des associations
de bénévoles n'est pas le même et de
l'autre côté on a une pression vers
l'efficience qui pousserait à réduire ce
qu'on appelle les petites collectes qui
font moins de 40 ou 30 don alors même
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une situation
où comme en fait les pour dire les
choses les collectes ne font pas 100 %
de l'objectif attendu elles font plutôt
en ce moment 90 % de ce qui est prévu
bah les les collectes qui hier don on
aurait pu se passer parce qu'elles
étaient moins efficientes moins
efficientes aujourd'hui une collecte à
40 dons 50 dons surtout si dedans il y a
des phénotypes rares en fonction de là
où elle est faite elle peut-être très
intéressante et donc ça fait énormément
de paramètres à prendre en compte pour
assurer voilà pour assurer le le
l'efficacité de la réponse
et pour ce qui est de de
de de l'incitation au don je pense aussi
que et c'est un des points qui est
évoqué par le programme innovadon
notamment il y a même même si on il
n'est pas question d'aller vers le don
rémunéré comp tenu de la du temps que
prend la PLMA ferise et de l'enjeu de
souveraineté sanitaire sur les le
développement de la filière plasma il y
a sans doute des une réflexion et une
discussion à conduire avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes
sur comment assurer la neutralité
financière de ce don c'est-à-dire la
personne qui est prête à prendre 2 heur
de son temps et à se déplacer jusqu'à
une maison du don est-ce qu'on rend pas
plus facile la possibilité pour elle
d'obtenir le défraement de ses frais de
déplacement voilà des des incitations
qui ne sont certainement pas une
rémunération du don encore une fois mais
en tout cas assurer le fait que la
personne qui donne en plus pas n'y va
pas de sa poche pour si je peux dire
c'est en mauvais jeu de mot pour assurer
ce ce ce cet élan de de générosité sur
la
recherche il y a bien sûr une question
fondamentale de de finan
à laquelle madame la rapporteur générale
a
également fait
[Musique]
allusion la dotation de 100 million
d'euros à mon sens elle elle finance les
missission de service public la
recherche est une des missions que la
loi confie à l' FS en revanche ce qui
est de l'activité de
bioproduction qui est une activité pour
laquelle en réalité pour faire simple le
FS assume des risques que des
industriels ne voudrai pas prendre parce
que on sait pas où on va et vous l'avez
très bien dit et donc voilà un
établissement public comme le FS peut
assumer ses essais et voilà et attirer
aussi des industriels qui restent en
France pour essayer que ça fonctionne et
on a tout tout intérêt à ça mais il y a
un coût est-ce qu'il appartient à
l'assurance maladie par exemple de
financer ça je suis pas certain est-ce
qu'il faut pas plutôt chercher d'autres
financements alors il y a des choses qui
se font avec France 2030 voilà on peut
réfléchir à au mesena
euh donc je pense qu'il y a euh des des
axes de développement à rechercher euh
de ce côté-là pour vous avez parlé de
solidité c'est le bon terme il faut que
les les interlocuteurs les entreprises
privées avec lesquelles ça se fait avec
lesquelles se fait cette sous-traitance
et l'assurance que c enfin ça peut
s'inscrire dans la durée et que le FS il
a l'assise pour faire ça jusqu'à ce
qu'on sache ce que donne le le projet
sur lequel on travaille sur le
changement de régime de TVA si je me
souviens bien il était imposé
par des questions européennes et donc
voilà je doute fort que on
puisse y revenir ouais
euh les madame la rapporteur général
donc sur le les questions sur le le
budget est-il la la le nouveau modèle
économique répond-t-il à tous les enjeux
euh alors pour la bioproduction par
exemple j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire
que il faut compléter pour sécuriser et
puis il y a la la question pour laquelle
je ne m'avancerai pas beaucoup parce que
encore une fois je n'ai pas discuté avec
tout le monde et j'ai souligné qu'il y
avait de multiples acteurs c'est celle
du plasma qu'est-ce qu'on construit pour
l'avenir de la filière plasma et là il y
a deux aspects financiers il y a le
déficit que gén la collecte de plasma et
la session au LFB déficit que ça génère
pour le FS et donc quelle compensation
puisqu'on n pas au prix de vente qui est
observée dans les dans les pays
européens donc si on veut développer si
on veut aller jusqu'à 1,4 million de
litres par an ça veut dire un déficit
augmenté pour le FS alors il y a bien
sûr la volonté de le faire mais voilà
comment on finance ça et puis y a le
financement de
l'investissement les machines
la réouverture de de maison du don pour
assurer un meilleur mariage territorial
et donc à un moment il faut qu'il a une
stratégie qui soit qui soit définie par
l'ensemble des acteurs et qui qui
prévoit un financement donc je vois au
moins ces deux point et je crois que le
le
ministre lorsque vous avez discuté de
l'article 31 il a fait lui-même allusion
jeudi
dernier sur la la recherche à tirer les
les chercheurs et proposer euh une
qualité de de produit je vous rejoins
totalement enfin c'est c'est c'est
parfaitement le l'objectif le FS c'est
un établissement qui
euh qui doit garder cette expertise sur
la cellule et en tirer le meilleur
bonnet bénéfice que ça soit pour la
recherche sur les médicaments de
thérapie innovant euh ou sur le la
drpanocytose bien sûr donc euh
euh nous sommes enfin voilà je je
partage tout à fait le cette ambition
sur le
laadpanocytose alors je je n'ai pas de
d'indication précise sur le coût ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que
euh selon les données que j'ai c'est à
peu près 30000 personnes en France qui
sont seruraient atteintte de
drpanocytose 10 à 20000 de ces personnes
qui ont vraiment besoin de transfusion
régulière encore aujourd'hui parce que
les il n'y a pas d'autres réponses et
donc avec toutes les questions que ça
pose sur le la la capacité à leur donner
euh les les les poches qui font qu'elles
vont pas développer une Alou
immunisation et générer ensuite des des
difficultés médicales mais donc c'est ça
veut dire quand même en terme de de
phénotype sans aller forcément jusqu'au
sang rare mais de phénotype adapté il
faut assurer une collecte la plus la
plus à même de répondre à ses besoins
sur les travaux avec la Haute Autorité
de santé sur le dépistage systématique
je n'ai pas là non plus de d'éléments
extrêmement précis mais je pourrais vous
les apporter dans dans un second temps
pour ce qui est de la recherche et de
elle elle porte aussi à l' FS sur la la
capacité à apporter une réponse la plus
la plus appropriée possible avec le
moins effectivement de d'effet
secondaires enfin il y a non seulement
les thérapies géniques sur lesquelles il
y a un travail mais et sur les des
alternatives à la simple transfusion
mais aussi un des recherches
sur par rapport à l'outil simple
transfusion comment on répond encore
mieux aux besoins des des
populations et pour les questions de
Madame pumierol alors l'attractivité
c'est la clé de de beaucoup de de choses
donc rattraper le le retard madame la
rapporteur générale j'avais pas répondu
complètement sur qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui reste à faire par rapport à à
l'application du Segur il y a le euh
tout tout le champ notamment de la
classification qui figure dans la
convention collective de l'fs qui aurait
dû être révisé il y a déjà 8 ans
maintenant euh c'est une question qui
est reportée d'année en année euh je
pense que là on va y arriver c'estàdire
on va s'y mettre et euh c'est là qu'on
doit
répondre à tous les enjeux qui sont
dessiner des parcours répondre au aux
contraintes opérationnelles enfin
vraiment moderniser tout ça et assurer
une une réponse dans dans la
durée et puis sur la recherche madame
pomérol je crois que je j'ai pas mal
répondu très bien merci Monsieur Pacou
on va continuer il encore si
intervenants donc je me un peu concis
Annie lurou
oui je vais être assez rapide parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de questions que je
souhaitait poser qui ont déjà été posés
auxquels vous avez répondu je vous
remercie mais attirer quand même votre
attention sur l'attractivité des métiers
de l'établissement alors vous avez dit
que c'était la convention en collective
était répétée d'année en année reporté
d'année en année donc nous comptons
vraiment sur vous pour que bah dans les
premiers défis à relever celui-là celui
de de l'attractivité des métiers et de
la juste rémunération aussi des
professionnels qui travaillent sur dans
ces établissements et puis euh sur le
volet recherche ça suppose aussi que
vous soyez attractif pour les
biologistes et chercheurs euh et je
constate que là aussi comme dans
beaucoup de d'autres établissements
d'ailleurs on est en déficit de
démographie médicale avec un nombre de
postes vacants importants donc je ne
sais pas pas quels sont vos leviers pour
euh et ben pour voir déjà les postes
vacants et relever le défi en matière de
recherche sur le plasma moi j'avais une
question alors je vous n'avez peut-être
pas la réponse mais vous l'avez un tout
petit peu abordé sur le maillage
territorial dans mon département il y a
une maison du don alors est-ce ce
suffisant alors que le besoin est
surtout sur ce champ là et puis on a un
vieillissement aussi des bénévoles qui
accompagne le FS euh bon des des enfin
une campagne de communication autour de
du don parce que le modèle nous y sommes
très très attachés donc serait à mon
avis nécessaire qui servirait autant les
bénévoles qui accompagnent l'fs que les
donneurs c'est vrai qu'il y a de
nombreux jeunes qui s'y qui y vont mais
bon peut-être qu'il y a aussi à à
renouveler en tous les cas
c'est un un défi aussi à à relever donc
je vais pas aller plus loin sur la vente
de
produits on est à des tarifs largement
inférieurs peut-être que là aussi sur le
modèle économique il y a peut-être un
effort particulier à demander progressif
peut-être mais nécessaire pour assurer
la pérénité de l'établissement merci
merci la parole à cine broulin merci
monsieur le Président vous avez monsieur
expliqué les différentes pistes que vous
souhaitetiez travailler et notamment et
ça nous semble tous important compte
tenu des questions qui sont posé à la
fois la souveraineté et l'attractivité
la reconnaissance des personnels qui
vont de paire parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un genre de
course de vitesse qui est en train de se
nouer votre prédécesseur enfin le
président par intérim nous expliquit
pendant une audition sur le PLFSS qu'il
y avait désormais des collectes que qui
devaient être annulé
faute de personnel en nombre suffisant
et donc on voit bien que c'est un espèce
de cercle vicieux qui peut se mettre en
place qui fait que le manque de
personnel le manque de reconnaissance de
de des professions mais fait qu'on est
plus à terme forcément en capacité
d'assurer cette souveraineté alors qu'on
on le dit tous on y tient beaucoup donc
enfin comment est-ce que vous vous
imaginez faire un petit peu ce ce choc
d' activité pour vraiment enrayer au
plus rapidement euh cette
situation sur la nécessité
de de d'aller vers enfin de d'avoir des
bénévoles plutôt plus jeunes et de les
fidéliser où est-ce qu'on en est et quel
développement vous imaginez au collectes
de sang sur les lieux de travail sur les
lieux d'études parce que vous avez
évoqué les les associations de bénévoles
qui sont détermin et les collectivités
mais il y a peut-être aussi d'autres
lieux qui peuvent se prêter à la
collecte pour justement fidéliser des
gens qui sont plutôt des actifs et enfin
pour financer le les activités de
recherche vous avez posé une question
qui semblait en effet très pertinente
est- à l'Assurance Maladie de financer
cette part là en revanche je suis plus
sceptique sur le mesena que vous avez
imaginé parce qu'évidemment ça peut
ouvrir la voix à ce que certaines
activités de recherche soi financé
d'autres pas et qu'il me semble que la
puissance publique doit garder son rôle
d'orientation dans la recherche qui doit
être effectuée
merci parole au Pr patria oui merci
monsieur le Président très brièvement
merci Monsieur Pacou vous avez je crois
à la fois très bien évoqué l'ensemble
des défis des efforts qui ont été faits
des efforts à faire l'essentiel des
questions a été posé je vis vous poser
simplement une petite petite question
subsidiaire la relation de le FS avec
les collectivités locales à la fois sur
le plan de des moyens techniques de
l'aide qui peut être rapporté par les
collectivités et sur peut-être aussi
peut-être du sursaut de vocation à
donner le sang à certain nombre
d'habitants dans les
territoires très bien merci la parole à
Marie do
haschliman merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président une question
concernant l'accès enfin votre
organisation dans les territoires
ultramarins vous avez évoqué les
difficultés si j'ai bien compris
l'absence de d'établissement à Mayotte
et en Guyane alors eu égard à la
prévalence de de la drpanocytose dans
ces territoires et à la nécessité de
prendre en charge de façon soutenue les
patients qui en souffrent je voudais
savoir comment vous vous organisez
est-ce que vous avez envisagé de
remédier à ces difficultés j'ai cru
comprendre aussi que pour Mayotte il y
avait aussi des difficultés liées à deux
points notamment euh les problèmes
migratoires qui sont une réalité
difficile à contenir mais aussi la
prévalence du paludisme qui n'est pas
éradiqué est-ce qu'il y a des des
perspectives pour que cette situation
soit gérée de façon optimale et enfin un
deuxième point qui concerne le défi de
de de votre organisation dans le cadre
des des jop de 2024 euh contte tenu de
la durée de vie limitée des prod Sangin
la ville qu'est-ce que vous envisagez
comme organisation est-ce que vous
imaginez des approvisionnements à partir
de pays voisins européens proches ou
est-ce que vous comptez renforcer les
collectes et des appels au don merci la
parole à Al Milon
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Pacou d'abord veuillez accepter mes
excuses mais en début de matinée j'ai
donné priorité au au maire de Vaucluse
euh je je voulais vous poser une
question par rapport à la dotation dont
vous avez un petit peu parlé la dotation
qui a été votée de 200 millions d'euros
j'ai regardé vos vos résultats 2023 les
pertes sont sont estimées à 58 million
d'euros pour
l'instant je voulais vous poser une
question précise d'abord vous faites des
produits dérivés à partir de dons que
vous vendez à l'assurance maladie et
l'assurance maladie vous donne quand
même par ailleurs une dotation de 100
million d'euros et j'ai posé une
question à monsieur le ministre il m'a
pas véritablement bien
répondu la Cour des comptes en juin
dernier ici même a constaté que
l'assurance maladie finançait beaucoup
d'agences et qu'elle n'avait pas de de
pouvoir de décision à l'intérieur de ces
agences est-ce que l'assurance maladie
qui vous finance à hauteur de 100
millions a un pouvoir de décision dans
les décisions que vous pouvez prendre
étant donné que vous n'êtes nommé plutôt
par le gouvernement que par l'assurance
maladie et le gouvernement si je sais
bien vous finance
pas très bien et pour la dernière
question qualifé qualifé merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Directeur merci
tout d'abord pour votre présentation
claire et précise en tout cas moi j'ai
j'ai deux
questions la première quelles sont vos
relations avec les les établissements
usagers et j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y a
un certain nombre de millions d'euros
d'impayés qui vous sont d et qui qui
traînent dans les placards est-ce que
c'est une fake news ou si c'est une
réalité et et et la deuxième plus
pratique je pense qu'il est important
qu'il y ait une communication importante
vis-à-vis du grand public quand on parle
et je suis favorable bien sûr de
développement industriel et autres comme
vous souhaitez le faire de de vraiment
de bien expliqué au public le coût que
vous avez pour ces produits sanguins que
vous avez par des dons et qui sont qui
sont payants par la suite c'est
important de de remettre un peu tout ça
à l'ordre du jour parce que j'ai
l'impression que comme ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises que ça a été un peu
oublié par le grand public merci très
bien monsieur Pacou je vous laisse
répondre à cette cette série de de
questions merci monsieur le
président
alors sur le pour les questions
concernant le la problématique des des
ressources humaines et de de
l'attractivité comme je l'ai dit le le
l'un des des premiers chantiers ça sera
de de mettre à place qui n'a pas pu être
conduit jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur
le notamment sur la révision de de la
convention collective et de la
classification il m'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'aller beaucoup plus loin
là-dessus parce que c'est une discussion
qui il s'agit de
lancer avec les organisations avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes donc
vous comprenez bien
que je peux ici affirmer ma volonté de
la de la conduire mais rentrer dans le
dans le détail de de des mesures au-delà
de vous dire quelles sont les
orientations
c'est-à-dire dépoussierer tout ça
prendre en compte l'évolution des
métiers et des besoins du système de
santé parce qu'ils sont plus les mêmes
que en il y a 15 ans quand la convention
a été définie on voit bien même le le le
modèle économique lui-même doit être
réformé donc les métiers ont évolué le
le FS a une politique avec le soutien
des des autorités de tutelle de de de
prise en compte des des de tous les les
praticiens en tous les les intervenants
en pratique avancé de voilà de de de
s'appuyer sur les les infirmières là où
autrefois on s'appuyait sur un médecin
de s'appuyer sur des techniciens de
laboratoire confirmé là où avant on
s'appuyait sur les seulement sur les
biologistes et donc ça veut dire qu'on
va dessiner des des parcours plus riches
dans le temps s'appuy aussi sur le
l'outil de formation dont dispose le FS
qui ayant récupéré l'émission de de
l'INTS a pu développer ce qui est le le
campus EFS c'est-à-dire un outil de
formation interne et donc c'est aussi ça
l'attractivité c'est le sonnant et
triébuchant bien sûr mais c'est aussi
euh
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on raconte
aux personnes qui veulent qui viennent
s'inscrire dans dans cet établissement
dont tout le monde convient qu'il a un
rôle vital essentiel mais encore faut-il
que les personnes qui viennent voilà
puissent s'y dessiner un parcours donc
c'est c'est ça l'enjeu et c'est ce que
je ce dont je discuterai avec les
équipes et les représentants du
personnel sur
la la recherche et là aussi la capacité
à tirer ben la la la première la
première modalité c'est de d'être solide
sur ses bases et de et d'avoir les les
financements la capacité financière
sachant qu'on s'inscrit dans un
écosystème euh avec les les organismes
de recherche CNRS inscerme avec les
universités avec les CHU tout ça se fait
dans des unités mixtes de recherche où
le FS est partie prenante de avec bien
d'autres acteurs donc ce qu'il faut
assurer c'est que le FS quand il quand
il s'engage là-dedans ça soit pour pour
les années nécessaires euh concernant le
le maillage territorial est
l'unique maison du don dans les côtes
d'armort il y a même des départements
puisque bien sûr on a on a 90 maisons du
don en plasma feris il y a des
départements où il n'y en a pas euh et
donc des donneurs qui voudraient pouvoir
donner mais qui disent ben moi il
faudrait que je fasse 100 km pour donner
du plasma donc c'est compliqué euh donc
il y a bien sûr dans le je parlais de de
ce plan plasma à définir avec le LFB et
l'ensemble des acteurs de de la filière
et bien sûr la question de de la
capacité à ouvrir de nouveaux sites et à
aller d'ailleurs assez vite pour assurer
une meilleure couverture du territoire
en en prenant en compte bien sûr les les
les données démographiques notamment
pour que cette collecte soit plus
efficiente
possible sur les le travail avec les les
bénévoles et les les le le ce que vous
avez évoqué comme le le vieillissement
des des bénévoles et les comment on
conduit les campagnes je crois que euh
alors le FS a a travaillé sur tous les
les déterminants du don a conduit des
des travaux avec avec les bénévo dans
euh sous le la le pilotage de de
plusieurs directeurs régionaux
d'établissement dans lefs social Lab il
apparaît qu'en fait les les jeunes
souhaitent toujours s'engager il y a
des donc c'est c'est une question qui
est compliquée le le vieillissement il
peut y avoir un vieillissement mais il y
a toujours des jeunes qui veulent
s'engager dans le dans la la cause du du
don du sang et de plasma euh je ferai un
lien avec la la la question du président
patria sur ce qui est conduit avec les
collectivités parce que parmi les les
pistes qui me semblent intéressantes
c'est notamment ce qui a été
signé à la fin de l'année dernière
c'est-à-dire la nouvelle convention on
est en plein dans l'actualité pour le
coup la nouvelle convention tripartite
entre le FS l'AMF et euh la Fédération
des donneurs de 100 bénévoles euh qui
évoque tout
un toute une liste de de de pistes de de
d'actions que peuvent conduire chacun de
leur côté les les trois acteurs et pour
les communes en valorisant sur le le
site de la mairie euh euh le don du sang
et de plasma en indiquant comment c'est
possible en renvoyant sur les
possibilités euh du côté de l'fs en
valorisant chaque année des communes qui
sont montrées dans le le partenariat don
du sang particulièrement euh dynamique
et qui ont qui ont su mettre à
disposition des lieux parfois qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire quand
évidemment ça peut concerner peut-être
des des collectivités un peu plus
grosses mais euh voilà des des lieux
plus insolites ou des équipements
culturels ou euh euh bien sûr éducatif
ou ou sportif euh donc je pense aussi
que dans dans l'aspect
rajeunissement on peut penser au travail
que peuvent conduire les bénévoles avec
justement le milieu culturel le milieu
des fédérations sportives les club
sportifs et donc en fait c'est un c'est
là aussi c'est un écosystème qui qui
doit faire appel à toutes les
générations puisque encore une fois on
peut donner son sang de de 18 à 70 ans
euh alors le le le cercle vicieux des
des collectes annulées et la la question
de du
choc d'attractivité le le l'aspect RH
est bien
sûr fondamental alors il il y a pas que
l'annulation des de de collectes 1600
collectes annulées pour des raisons RH
en 2022 à peu près autant cette année je
pense il y a aussi des collectes qui
parce que tel agent de de lefs des
collectes Mobil tel agent de lefs est
absent ce jour-là ben sont en fait vont
se faire dans un format un peu réduit
donc la collecte qui devait partir sur
100 rendez-vous et faire 100 poche ne
pourra en faire que moins donc enfin
c'est c'est aussi un problème dans la
capacité à remplir les les
objectifs annuel
donc c'est un chantier considérable en
matière de de RH de de de redéfinition
du du format de de ces
collectes sur le la recherche et le
l'impact du messena à mon sens c'est
bien sûr la le pilotage des des actions
de recherche il doit rester dans dans la
main de de de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et des des recherches qui qui
sont financés il s'agit de de s'appuyer
sur comme la loi d'ailleurs le permet
déjà elle prévoit que le FS peut
recevoir des des dons des lèes donc il
s'agit sans doute de donner une autre
dimension à ces sources de financement
mais en aucun cas de confier le pilotage
des des activités de recherche à à de
tierces parties
euh pour les questions ultramarines
Mayotte Guyane et la question de la la
drpanocytose alors en Mayot à Mayotte et
en Guyane il n'y a en l'état pas de
collecte principalement pour des raisons
sanitaires épidémiologiques avec
effectivement un maotte encore une
prévalence de du paludisme mais aussi ce
qu'on appelle les arbr oviros
c'est-à-dire la dingue le chikongunia
enfin et donc sur le paludisme il y a
probablement une perspective
que à terme de même que à la Réunion le
la problématique a été traité si je puis
dire on peut espérer qu'un jour il y ait
plus de de de paludisme à Maillotte et
que on puisse avancer vers des condition
qui qui permettrait de faire une une
collecte sachant que la problématique
est la même en guyan c'està-dire que ce
qui prédomine c'est bien sûr l'objectif
de sécurité sanitaire et donc tant que
la situation épidémiologique ne permet
pas de procéder à des collectes parce
que en réalité on serait amené s'il y
avait une collecte à jeter beaucoup de
poches soit parce que on il y aurait des
des des amis des maladies portées par
les moustiques les les arbovirouses ou
aussi parce que il y a il y a une
prévalence dans ces département toujours
un peu plus fort de C de d'hépatite par
exemple et donc des collectes qui qui
amènerait à faire un investissement très
important mais qui en réalité se
révélerait non efficiente pour des
raisons de de sécurité par ailleurs pour
ce qui est de de la
réponse à la au traitement de la
drpanocytose comme pour l'ensemble du
système de transfusionnel français ces
départements bénéficient de la
solidarité nationale organisée au sein
de lefs comme vous savez il y a des
régions qui sont exportatrices de
produits sanguins parce qu'elles ont une
cololl
qui génère plus de poches et d'autres
qui sont importatrices on parle de
région française je parle pas de
d'exportation et d'importation vers
l'étranger et donc pour pour Mayotte par
exemple l'apport des poches nécessaires
et adapté au phénotype des personnes qui
sont drpanocitaires à Mayotte se fait
principalement depuis le dispositif
transfusionnel de la réunion avec un
apport aussi de la métropole qui fait
que la couverture des phénotypes qui
existent à Mayotte est très bonne en
fait elle est même meilleure parfois que
ce qu'on peut observer en métropole
parce que cet apport se fait notamment
par la Réunion et que donc la la réponse
en terme de groupe sanguin de
compatibilité sur la transfusion est
même un peu mieux assuré à Mayotte il y
aurait bien sûr par ailleurs un je l'ai
pas évoqué mais un intérêt à terme à
développer la collecte en Guyane et à
Mayotte parce qu'on on y trouverait
aussi des phénotypes justement plus
recherchés pour traiter les persones
atteint de
drepanocytose sur le les Jeux olympiques
et
paralympiques quelle organisation ben en
fait c'est le ça sera le
principalement un dispositif sur place
c'està-dire adapter les les ressources
disponibles de lefs au sein de
l'établissement de transfusion sanguine
d'île-de-fance donc avec un système
d'astreinte pour faire face à des des
situations qui pourrait se se présenter
donc bien sûr la mobilisation de du
système région
mais aussi un apport qui qui est prévu
en cas de nécessité de l'ensemble des
régions qui collecteront plus en cette
période estival étant donné que les
l'appareil de collecte notamment les
collect Mobil vont plus vers le littoral
les littoraux français à cette période
et on voit toutes les collectes pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont des des des
bordures littorales qui ont des communes
qui qui accueillent les ns du sang en
juillet et en
août et sur le le le rôle monsieur le
Président Milon de l'assurance
maladie et de par rapport à l'évolution
du du financement de
l'établissement l'assurance maladie a un
représentant au sein du conseil
d'administration qui à mon avis ne
répondra que partiellement à la question
que vous posez puisque je pense que vous
faites référence à d'autres are capacité
de de décision
euh c'est peut-être quelque chose ce qui
qui qui méritera d'être regardé je je
sais en tout cas
que le représentant ou la représentante
de l'assurance maladie est extrêmement
attentive à bien sûr à au devenir de
l'fs et à la part que qui que prend
l'assurance maladie dans son financement
donc je pense que c'est une question qui
avec cette nouvelle dotation va prendre
une une prénance plus importante donc
effectivement nous pourrons reparler
désormais cette dotation va nous permett
de nous voir aussi je l'espère sur les
conditions voilà l'évolution de la
situation de l' FS donc on pourra suivre
ce point ensemble
monsal et pardon effectivement je tourne
la page puisque monsieur califet m'avait
interrogé sur les relations avec les
établissement de santé
et la problématique des impayés alors
effectivement il y a des des
établissements
qui ont des impayés à l'égard de
l'établiss
Français du Sang bon ce sont des
situations qui ont vocation à à se
résoudre dans le temps la question de
des des relations
avec avec lesétablissement français du
sang elle est elle est compliquée parce
que si on veut être
honnête on pourrait aussi indiquer que
il est arrivé dans au cours des
dernières années que après que la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avait
fixé
lame que le Parlement avait voté il est
arrivé que le gouvernement procède à des
hausses de tarifs or les enveloppes pour
l'établissement de santé étaient fixé et
donc le financement en face des hausses
de tarifs pour les sessions de produits
sanguins au sein des hôpitaux n'était
pas forcément prévu donc il y a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs types de
situations il y a des établissements de
santé qui sont dans des situations plus
difficiles donc voilà tout ça est
traité par par le
FS vocation à être réduit et puis enfin
sur la la communication à l'égard du
grand public et la pédagogie ben c'est
un un champ très très important on
observe dans les pays européens qui sont
tous confrontés comme la France on n'est
pas isolé dans la problématique de la de
la montée en puissance de la collecte de
plasma il y a aussi un enjeu de
communication
expliquer à nos concitoyens que le don
du sens c'est très important mais le don
de plasma c'est important aussi c'est
c'est différent parce que ça pose moins
de contraintte comme je l'ai dit ça
prend un peu plus de temps leur
expliquer à ce quoi ça sert qu'est-ce
qu'il y a au bout les les médicaments
dérivés du plasma qu'est-ce qu'il
permett de soigner qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du du du don du sang ou de plasma donc
il faut jamais relâcher aussi cette ce
travail de de pédagogie et d'information
de nos
concitoyens merci Monsieur Pacou en tout
cas vous avez fait bien bener votre
action de communication vous avz des
sénateur voilà je remercie donc pour
cette audition et puis suivra les les
évolutions voilà de le FS merci beaucoup
alors en attendant